e aí
a tarde toda a gente começar aqui quem
fala
e vamos lá como eu fico deitada meu nome
é cláudia costa sua mulher e se eu posso
falar sempre que a gente combina para
falar sobre mulher tu ser mulher
eu nunca parei de se fosse o favor de me
quisesse diferente é
a falar o que é
eu nunca pensei que eu era mulher
diferença é
bom então é o que é um passo que eu fiz
como eu trabalho com isso como eu uso
dele a empresa não tem um pouco tempo
aqui eu não quero gastar nosso tempo que
falando de mim ou da minha história
ortográfico
a copa mais de mim fala sempre que eu
ponho blusa eu acordo com ele para ele
aqui abaixo o novo meu nome lá
o que ele tava mentindo
a paixão então quando eu só vai né fábio
uma e conta cá
bom então vamos lá
o rosto mais um pouquinho só para saber
mas ela me fala só tá louco
e nós estamos livro de história é isso
que eu vou contar para você história
o méxico a gente faz parte das nossas
vidas quando a gente busca na escola
desafio como foi a aula
tô esperando me conta aqui então hoje eu
vim contar uma história pra vocês tantas
histórias que eu sou apaixonada que eu
amo que eu gosto eu e em especial para
uma história dessa menina filha era
filha de um casal nós vamos visitar a
vitória dela é um dia muito especial que
deveria ter sido já tomou nacional
a pena só para escola havia combinado a
casa que faz cair ela no colégio aí
colégio disco
tô esperando o pai agora você não faz
e ele me pedindo começaram a chegar lá
do outro lado só dela não pai tá escolar
dele quem será quem seria ele ia ficar
muito próximo da família muito a minha
que seus pais que isso ele tava fazendo
essa pessoa
oi baixinha próximos a rua você tava
ansiosa por essa coisa de espera e quais
as empresas quando vai passar reto e não
para
o advogado com a conversa que não aqui
o senhor ok tem um jeito que está em
casa da casa de papel normal eu sempre à
noite os pais achavam em casa
e na rede pública ela irmão tá tranquilo
uma menina normal
o trabalho que ela é porque meu pai
e aí para você no colégio
é aquela né seja mais ele itavó
e ela tem três hoje
hoje foi corrido papai vocês aí foi no
dia corrido que houvesse olhar para o
rosto do pai ela serve
é mas ela tava nenhum filha mais naquele
momento ela só conseguia perceber que é
mentira e o quanto ela estava aqui ó
é realizado afinal a mamãe internet
médica tava dando uma mulher não faça
isso não faça aquilo de direito e feche
as pernas então vou seus primos você não
é um você é uma menina então nesse
momento quando ela sentiu sufocada ou
quando ela corria o risco de apanhar
e naquela época
e ela é o papai quer comigo e o pai dela
tava estava baixo da camisa camiseta
então três dias então esse é um homem
idealizado que tava like 20 usar ela é
e ela sou eu
o que eu vou colocar como foi respeitado
isso
e é uma simples que não faz nada com
essa voz fazer s
e quando eu falo e não fazendo as
pessoas não acreditam que trabalham com
tecnologia mas na verdade tecnologia
muito aquilo que veio depois que a gente
nasceu não conhecia né nós não chamamos
as outras técnicas que eu sou grato
eu também tô falando que eu sou pequeno
botãozinho e a loja sente então pros
nossos filhos pros nossos netos
e tal então eu me lembro muito bem de
ficção alcançar o diabo deixa eu fechar
a minha geral a minha vó lavava as
louças para tirar eu era minha tirinha e
aí ela fez um banhozinho porque o
suficiente que mostra tinha que lavar
louça não podia ficar com quem gosta
assim
se tu for eu vou fazer um convite muito
bem porque ele
e na minha cabeça também com estudo eu
posso
é isso não fica mais que a gente vai
querer que eu ficava com ele se eu vou
aguentar ficar com raiva ela quiser
porque ele tinha diferença então região
não é 13 anos foram bem significativos
da minha vida
o meu pai se separaram indo praí sonho
de muita alegria tem previsão
oi tá boa
on the rocks
e sem cortar
os novos mudamos caído áfrica na índia e
hoje eu tinha vivido até os meus 13 anos
onde o instituto victor civita orientada
e mudamos para uma cidade que não
conhecia ninguém que dava dar errado
também não desligava e que eu não pense
em jogo mais ninguém que eu não tinha
muitos e eu nunca mais seria isso
e olha ela tava frio minha mãe dela
falou talvez no assunto desesperada
nossa gente tá então dentro de nós que
vai lá corta configurar o homem armado
em cama de novo graças a deus que me deu
uma linda eu amo enfiar toda a minha
vida a gente conseguir e eu sempre me
senti logo uma diabo aquela ansiedade
pela cidade para pessoas eu não pequenas
da minha filha apaga mas meus pais não
admitindo que a filha
a estudar na capital afinal
é uma coisa uma coisa eu te falo que eu
posso até tá vontade de forma
e aí
se preocupar para eu falar você não vai
ter um negócio lá e rápido
me sinto quando é bastante eu separei
dois fatos para você porque muitas vezes
as pessoas contam que hora e não sabem
né tá na história então é eu tinha um
tênis vermelho depois que eu usei um
remédio para me lembrar não é matemática
que a gente fica longe pelo contrário
está encostada numa rede de distribuição
em paratinga e eu muitas vezes não tinha
dinheiro para voltar para casa eu vi na
pele do colégio que eu estava até a casa
dos pais adoravam eu me arruma lá e meio
daquele sol de bem vestida
é fácil né
é mas é uma forma de olhar para o outro
que não é legal final mamãe menino todos
os dias no sol de meio-dia e lembra de
um dia que a minha mãe não tinha leite
chata e eu não entendi que a minha mãe
olhou para ela não tem mamar
e aí
o meu pai meu pai que ainda fazendo eu
vou ter que ir fazendo aquela parte
aquele acho que minha mãe do thiago aqui
pegar o dinheiro para minha mãe que ia
matar aqui e um dia não tinha olha em
casa tinha comida
ah tá bom gente tem face
eu não sei se eu pagar com uma garota
que tinha quintal olha aí na casa que
fez uma farofa com farinha de mandioca
e ele já vai dormir
o piru para sustentar os filhos nessa
página
e eu já tinha amanhecido a violência
coração
e não encaixar respeito daquelas meninas
populares do colégio então muitas os
seus caminhos e suas unhas feitas
e como isso começou a mudar quando eu
fui escolheu que eu queria fazer da
minha vida
a ficar tão linda faça direito
e eu queria sempre gente e eu falei que
eu ia fazer você espera alguns dias que
sair faculdade de tecnologia e ela já
tem que isso não dá nem até porque
ninguém foi que falou e brigou pode
fazer a popular daqui amanhã você também
e mesmo assim eu fui fiz e aí eu passei
a mudar a minha vida novamente três anos
complicadas porque eu até pensei que tu
estava na minha vida dos 16 aos 19 eu
passei uma faculdade com 16 eu abri eu
não treinar com 17 que eu perdi a
virgindade constitui de um gravei
conjunto de figurar na página vamos lá
eu nunca foi o amor da minha vida mas
ela vai falar no tom sabia que comprovam
os amigos a gente morou durante 18 anos
17 18 anos
eu descobri que estava grávida mas eu vi
um caos familiar tem que respeitar o que
eu achava com a minha vida possa fazer
natação profissional porque eu tava
precisando muito presa aqui ninguém
sabia o que fazia faz nesse site naquela
época era assistir tá então a vida vai
gastando mas quando for eu vou viver
dentro eu chego a 110 cinza cheguei
vestir 52
e eu ganhei um prêmio regional concorri
ao pega nacional que significa missões
rosa aparecer na tv e aparecer
o que você tem conhecida
profissionalmente daquilo que eu fazia
né mas laden continua
oi oi
e aí
o que a gente tem que estar com raiva
sou beirada então pode chorar né
e eu tive três filhos já tendo a sofia e
o adulto lindos amores da minha vida e
eu me perdi nele
e muitas vezes nós pegamos muitos anos
que nos encontrarmos novamente
e vamos lá fazer os 34 35 36 anos eu já
tinha emagrecido tava 70 ativos 38 de
marketing e aí novo problema
é aquela sexual afinal você não pode ser
dona de uma empresa e crescer só por
competente se ver né com dormir com
ninguém
o que você faz aqui
oi e eu que sabia que não usado na
intenção de me recusei gente aqui sul
e foi algumas parou todos os meus
gatinhos estão fora queria era aquela
pert cabelo rolo de mas entendi foi
parar naquele momento
oi e aí como é que tava aconteceu porque
todos os ingredientes essas mulheres não
somos feitos de carne com as pessoas daí
eu escrever eu sei o inverno chegou a me
realmente fértil dois separei e o pai
a sociedade a pessoa que acharam da
minha
é você mesmo tamanho 34 anos ele está é
eu confiei nas pessoas erradas aqui
dentro de pessoas certas ela chega que a
gente eu não me machuque
a vida vai que eu tô falando da gente
tudo mais longe use cara sejam os dias
sempre lá só tem de volta
bom e como a gente percebe coisas que a
gente nunca imaginou que aconteceria
completo
e aí
o meu filho hoje trabalha aqui e o padre
a vocês eu não imaginava vida quadrada
dele
em todas as vezes que olhava pequenino
lembrar que eu faça bater nele
oi hoje é um orgulho eu falo que ele é o
meu grande amor da minha vida
e a minha mãe fez eu hoje mim não só se
a gente trabalha muitos eu tenho um
privilégio está com ela eu falo com ela
é minha sozinha sozinha é minha mundo
e ela é muito chata eu também sou muito
chata todos não são chatos aqui ficando
cada vez mais chato muito chato mês
passado para dizer olha aqui que a
pessoa não é normal diferente parte da
frente tipo os filhos em primeiro ele
fez o fazendo fazer e eu não permite
amar uma pessoa sem esperar nada só e me
deixa de gelada hoje você tava
conversando com uma amiga ela vai falar
porque a gente vai brincando né dura
pronta para uma filha de tanto apanhar
da vida e eu falei para ela assim mas a
gente de vir a pé mas a gente também
pode virar forte novo
e essa foi hoje infelizmente a mates
queimada vídeos são muito eu fiz o que
ela tem outro lado a sua filha tem
conseguido a família preconceito de
outras mulheres que seguem abaixo as
coisas e outra mulher né mas o amor
falando isso muito legal a gente foi
feito de bom mano eu ainda tenho sonhos
e continuam conquistar o sonho cara aqui
hoje é um sonho é a realização de um
sonho passarinhos placa seu passado ruim
que aquele sonho com muito mais
a memória para essa pessoa eu não
consigo me ver nela eu não eu não me
lembro chico com ela porque a gente tem
lá assistir arrastar sabe arrastando
tudo aqui não tiver bom a gente vai
rasgar meu casamento já tá ficando
relacionamentos vai rápido lavando o
chão corrente e ela resolveu vir aqui
porque
hoje eu quero falar com assistente
profissionais a falar para você passar
uma pessoa comum comum em dia que eu não
tô é baseado no dia que eu tô com meu
cabelo tipo achei ela entendeu aquela
coisa linda é só dar uma o dia todo
petista tem dia que eu não quero só tá
casa eu gosto de brincar com os meus
filhos eu sou uma pessoa como você e
ontem eu tava querendo passando e
pensando que eu poderia ter escolhido
como quer coisa para contar para você
mas eu resolvi mostrar que eu não fiz
forno cidade nova 6 horas ainda bem que
vocês tenham certeza de que ela era
superado a gente foi buscar acontecendo
de uma nota de cem dólar sempre valor
assim nós não importa o que eu faço com
ela posso marcar posso da posso rasgar
um pedacinho dela ela tem que fazer
assim não é
bom então
a estrada das pitas nós também somos
assim dependente do que acontece sem dó
nem aconteceram sem óleo então às vezes
sai errado mãe a melhor coisa que
poderia ter acontecido e uma não tem tem
um sabor só olhar horrível ruim e a
gente pode olhar que é bom vocês tudo já
minha aula tudo que nos custaram parar
no mercado de paz porque cochila passar
canetinha a gente tem que se movimentar
se fosse para ficar muito folgada ela
vai pedir uns pé nós iremos raízes então
se você quiser enganar muriqui a
problemas novamente mudar 10% a gente
não consegue controlar aquela que
acontece com a gente tá lendo os nossos
mas alguém não por cento é o que eu
aprendi de um passo ruim e eu a noite
acredito minha frente de você e que ela
fez também um
e aí